at a visit to the Parliament a member of
the [ __ ] riot group showed her
solidarity with the Magnitsky case
Magnitsky a lawyer died in prison in
2009 after alleged beating but what was
more bizarre was that he was tried and
guilty of tax fraud in 2013 at the choke
when you those nature those who are
responsible for Magnitsky's death should
not be subject to any kind of immunity
measures need to be taken to deal with
them at the mini plenary MEP voted in
favor of imposing sanctions and 32
Russian officials linked to his death
making a racket on our streets
especially in rush hour traffic by 2017
the first stage of new rules could be in
place to further reduce the level of
noise vehicles make but we're all
parties happy with the outcome some of
argue that lobbies have had too much
influence i'm not sure if everybody is
happy but i'm happy after nearly or
three years of the difficult work for
the health of citizens it's a bad result
the reporter mr. uski he was caught of
tabling as his compromise proposal limit
values drafted by Porsche which I find a
scandal
when we think of bees we think of honey
but bees do so much more they can help
pollinate crops and a key to food
production but what they also are is
endangered with entire species being
wiped out here at the Parliament
beekeepers vets scientists
industrialists and even Prince Albert of
Monaco all came together a conference to
take the fight to save bees forward for
its part Europe is banned certain
pesticides but more needs to be done
abakan sheena elliott almond aprecio
carissa bed aspires avoid a chinois
proceso de session avec de langue de
l'homme bottom poor permit hola Princesa
Jasper crow hop know so a pecan with a
subpoena